hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute meine damen und
herren ihr seht ihr eigenblut zu einer
basketball stellen ich befinde mich
heute nicht alleine sondern mit
tritt ganz deutschland hat nash mal wir
haben wie man es von einer basketball
challenge kennt einen basketball dabei
und ihr seht schon hier vorne was haben
wir denn hier einen kurs und ich sag
jetzt mal ganz gut was leute machen und
zwar werfen die köpfe mehr war nicht
drin denn von hier rein schaut auf jeden
fall haben uns heute etwas überlegt und
zwar machen wir nicht nur irgendeine
basketball tennis sondern wir haben uns
drei einzelnen challenge draußen sucht
und wir fangen direkt an mit der ersten
challenge wir werden uns sicher hier
hinstellen ich werd ich glaube ich dann
mal kurz im rucksack dahin 13 freiwürfe
doch mal selber nachdenken über einen
dummen fragen man muss hier auf der höhe
des rucksack stehen bisschen dass auf
der höhe des platz und hat den ball und
muss dann mit dem ball in den korb
treffen
ich bin so scheint in der tat jeder hat
sieben würfe und lukas du darfst
anfangen was denkst wer gewinnt das
ganze richtig laser lukas erster wurf
meine damen und herren ich mich schon
mal so ein bisschen rum gesehen das kann
ja gar nicht
[Applaus]
ich war hinten sehen die hilfe der denke
den schweini ach das war ja klar der
zweite von sieben würfen von lukas und
dabei sting dritter von lukas werte
haben und herrn los geht's du kannst
hier wieder so ein bisschen rum wir
sehen das kann ja gar nicht jetzt nimmt
er den ball in beide hände und schon
wieder ein ball mensch freunde das wird
eine ganz einfache challenge heute dass
ich vielleicht sagen aber du hast bisher
keinen reingemacht der fünfte wurf von
lukas geht da rein alter das ist dass es
nicht mehr normal wie scheiße s6 avant
von lukas er dribbelte wieder so ein
bisschen und denkt dann mit einer
vielleicht besser treffen habe ich dir
sagen ist nicht der fall
der sektor geht auch nicht rein wenn
spottete der und das traurige ist dass
wahrscheinlich sogar der hund hier
besser treffen würde junge du wirst ja
so dass ich meine es kann ja auch sein
dass ich einfach gar kein rein machen
werde und dann geht die ersten challenge
einfach unentschieden aus ja ok gewinnen
kannst du die schäden schon mal nicht
geworden
dadurch dass ich jetzt meinen ersten von
sieben freiwürfe rein gemacht hat habe
ich die challenge quasi schon gewonnen
also erste challenge geht allmählich
kritische leid dass so einen starken
gegner wie mich gehasst kommen wir nun
doch schon zur zweiten challenge meine
damen und herren und zu haben wir hier
noch den basketball effizienter vorne
befindet sich ein baum mitten auf der
wiese und die challenge jetzt wird sein
wir werden abwechselnd den ball dahin
werfen hin schießen hin colan keine
ahnung was und werden eher nicht wenn er
aber wer zuerst den baum berührt
gewinnen diese challenge da du vorhin
anfangen musste ist lukas mixtur an
fange ich jetzt an
ich bin irgendwann wir stellen hier
wieder den rucksack hin dass sie hat
dieser grenze wo der asphalt je mehr
oder weniger aufhört
warum fällt er in hier ist die grenze
das heißt ich versuche jetzt mal als
erstes den jungen die hunde hätten den
übels ab
wow
richtig teuren geologe machen eine
andere challenge das ist richtig
ekelhaft auf dieser wiese da das echt
harten matschig ist auf dieser vision
des harz schwierig ist aus 30 40 meter
mit einem basketball baum zutreffen
wären wir es jetzt machen dass wir
einfach schauen wer weiter werfen kann
das hier ist jetzt die markierung hier
vorne dieser komische silberne dings auf
dem boden wir gucken jetzt wer weiter
werfen kann also halter das war richtig
schlecht ich glaube wenn und den allein
kulas funktionär an wir machen das jetzt
einfach so dass ich nicht mit der kamera
da hinten zu den ball stelle wo ich
quasi hingeworfen habe und lukas du 50
gar nicht ich stelle mich jetzt auf
jeden fall mit der kamera hinten zum
ball lukas den ball zu und dann schauen
wir auf lukas weiter getroffen hat ich
habe die erste challenge richtig easy
gewonnen lukas hatte sieben freiwürfe
komplett daneben gehauen aber bei dieser
challenge jetzt habe ich hart verklagt
weil ich den vor dem baum geworfen
also hier vorne habe ich hingeworfen und
lukas steht jetzt da hinten das heißt er
muss auf jeden fall diese entfernung
hinkriegt was wir da sehen wir lucas wie
ein bisschen anspruch nimmt er hebt den
hand und er vorne und er läuft jetzt
nach vorne und er geht noch mal nach
hinten machte jetzt endlich neu heute
okay das ja okay da muss ich jetzt ganz
ehrlich zugeben dass der ball liegt
schon der zweite challenge geht an lukas
kleine rote kommen wir nun zu dritten
und letzten und vor allem auch
entscheidenden challenge meine damen und
herren wir befinden uns hier an einem
baum dass ich mein leben durch den baum
e klasse ist der moment meines lebens
auf jeden fall müssen wir uns hier neben
dem baum stellen müssen diesen was auch
immer das ist davon abwerfen freunde
dass man leicht davis das video ever
made und complete youtube cool freut
nicht jeder von uns beiden hat fünf
versuche und wird die nacheinander
abfertigen
und wir haben öfter diese feier
getroffen hat gewinnt 3 2 1
also das ist nicht so easy wir dachten
es schwierig muss ich schon zugeben
[Musik]
nach luca des zugewinns eine schule in
der schule zwei jahre natürlich habe
fünf jahren eingespielt dass ich fünf
jahre 50 jahre dicke witz gießen nichts
nicht versuchen wir mal 3com ich habe
ihm direkt dagegen
ich bin abgerutscht dieser ball ist so
fein von 330 sowie services for versuch
nummer vier freunde mit anlage und war
hinterher
ok lukas ich weiß nicht ob das gut war
zwei von fünf aber es war echt schwierig
also ich überlasse die jetzt hier den
ball ich nehme den kamera und nun meine
damen und herren ist dieser menschen
dran und das schaut reißen können 32 als
wenn junge das ist nicht wahr versuchen
nummer 2 von lukas wenn der schon drin
ist dann ist es mindestens ein
unentschieden von ihm hier das wäre auf
jeden fall ein gutes comeback lukas du
darfst jetzt werfen er nimmt den ball
das wird gerade eine einheit mit dem
ball geht runter wie er war nicht das
war sehr sehr eng dass ein vollidiot
versuch nummer 3 von lukas wir sehen ihn
er wird wieder eine einheit mit dem ball
oh mein gott
okay das unentschieden ist auf jeden
fall schon mal drin ich will nicht
wissen wie dreckig seine schuhe gleich
sind lukas ist sie das bewusst wenn du
diesen jetzt rein was noch zweifel dass
es rein machen wir den dagegen wir das
noch zwei versuche
wenn du ein von den beiden trifft da
hast einfach gewonnen gummibärchen
du stehst doch gar nicht am baum höheren
meter weiter hinten stehen am baum
direkt am baum hier ja ich stand da auch
wenn der reingeht dann nehme ich alles
zurück alter kommen du kannst dein
vorletzter versucht richter das hin
verschafft er es wirklich hier noch oft
nachdem er die erste challenge verloren
hat der war nicht mein gott alter der
letzte versuch wird jetzt entscheiden
freunde wir sehen hier ein blatt und da
unten ich schenke ich bin immer nicht
freuen da hinten trainiert übrigens
gerade next gomez lukas musste man auch
hier stehen der letzte versuch von lukas
wird er erschafft und jetzt in diesem
match nachdem er die für erste komplette
challenge übels verloren hat jetzt noch
zu gewinnen
[Applaus]
dehnhardt gespannt ob das jetzt eben
geschaffen wird er wird wieder ein
jetzt unfair ist einfach unfair die
stimmkraft ich habe verloren meine damen
und herren ich sehe es ein ich habe beim
basketball komplett rasiert okay du hast
einfach überhaupt nicht rasiert und ich
hab den ersten reihen gemacht beim
werfen habe ich alles falsch gemacht
seine taktik war viel besser weil es war
gefälle und lukas hat einfach bereut und
ich habe dumm in den rhein geworfen und
jetzt hier bei der dritten und letzten
challenge habe ich zweimal getroffen
lukas mit seinem letzten wurf das dritte
mal dass lukas an dich herzlichen
glückwunsch
ich habe jeglichen hände wegen herzrasen
jetzt habe ich auch rechte geändert wenn
euch dieses video hier gefallen hat
würden wir uns sehr über einen daumen
hoch freund lukas kann alles und in der
beschreibung verlinkt haben wir
vielleicht sogar auch was aufgenommen
hier ist da hab ich dich in tiefer
gefühle alles klar das war es jetzt hier
vom video das war es jetzt hier vom
video wenn es euch gefallen hat wie
gesagt lassen like da aber nicht meinen
kanal wir sehen uns jetzt kommt das auto
schießt das wasser das war's jetzt hier
vom wir können jetzt jemand den kanal
abonnieren oder
meinen shows checken jetzt findet ihr
zwei andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent seid könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]